hey all Peter Kumble fearless is here to
talk about Z Viper this tricky agent has
been burning and shocking the
competition since the original Street
Fighter 4 then shows no signs of
stopping anytime soon let's see what's
in store for her an ultra street fighter
for Viper players America Viper didn't
really have any decent medium range
attacks thereby forcing them to rely on
specialists to help reduce Vipers
dependency on special attacks her
crouching middle kick range has been
increased so that she can now connect
the attack from further out Vipers focus
attack has long been considered the
worst in the game due to its extremely
slow start off in an effort to increase
its usefulness as well as bring her up
to par with the rest of the cast all
levels of her e.x and red focus attacks
now come out three frames faster than
they used to balance us out however the
range at which these attacks hit have
been minimized as it hit a lot further
out than other focus attacks in the game
although not as thin as a typical sure
you can a Viper's heavy Thunder knuckle
attack was still rather effective at
stopping the opponent's advances trading
into an ultra in addition to being just
about an punishable when counsel him to
a forward dash to help even out their
risk versus reward viper is now slightly
more disadvantages when cancelling this
attack into a four - hitting Vipers
super in the middle of a combo was
frustrating for Viper players for two
reasons one it did less damage than
other supers in the game and two the
intended attack was typically Aniak
seismo performed incorrectly to fix this
the damage has been increased by 50 so
that when viper players do go for the
super that Elise get the standard damage
another fix applied with the change the
command on the super so that if it does
come out and hits entirely intentions
those fighting Piper had a hard time
knowing when to punish her whenever she
missed her ultra due to the large amount
of smoke on the street to help players
see what's happening that much more the
smoke has been reduced greatly which
means that she'll now be punished a
little bit more heavily so try not to
miss that ultra very often fight for has
been traditionally viewed as a character
who is Special Attack many and therefore
a bit one-dimensional yet effective with
the increase in effectiveness to her
basic attack she can now play a spacing
game like the rest attack Viper players
will however have to be a little less
reckless with the heavy thunder knuckle
this time around has one wrong guess to
foster the entire game
you